(audience claps and cheers)
- Alright, we've hit that time in the show
where I share something cool from
the pages of social media, this is
what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- 'Tis the season for ghost
stories and total spookiness
and one New York artist is bringing
the craziest tales of hauntings to life
with a series she calls "Inktober"
It's something she's been doing since 2018
and she turns them into books.
Everybody, let's say hi
to Jessica watching on NBC
for New York at three.
What's up Jessica?
(crowd cheers)
- Hi, how are you?
- [Kelly] I'm so good,
so how did you come up with this idea
- So, I've always had a
love for ghost stories
and all things spooky
and the series started
as a way for my to build my art portfolio
and I thought it would be really cool
to focus on folklore
from around the world.
And I basically started by doing a bunch
of research do a sketch based on
the story and then I'll head
into the inking process.
Um, I try to incorporate elements from
the story as I can
whether it's the clothing
from that time period
or sometimes if there's
an animal in the story
I'll include the skull or
the antlers of that animal.
Um, and by the end of
this month I'll have done
90 stories so far.
(audiences applauds)
- You are so incredibly gifted, my gosh.
It's so beautiful, so cool.
Um, we're looking at video of you creating
one of your favorites, so tell us
about the Lady From Boston.
- [Jessica] So, the Lady In Black
tells the tale of Melanie Lanier
and her husband was being kept prisoner
in Fort Warren in Boston Massachusetts.
So, she came up with a plan to free him
using a pickax to tunnel
through the prison
and unfortunately they were captured
and sentenced to death and it's said
that today her ghost still roams that area
and holding on to the
guilt of what happened.
And I thought the story
was just sorta tragic
so with my art I always try to combine
the creepy with the beautiful and a lot
of the responses to
the story have actually
been people who are
planning a trip to Boston
and now they get really excited that they
have a piece of spooky history
to bring with them now.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh my gosh,
what an intense story.
Well, thank you so much Jessica.
(crowd applauds)
- [Kelly] I'm liking your post right now.
- [Jessica] Thank you
(bell rings)
oh, thank you so much
- And that's not all
our season long partner
Pilot Pen Makers of Frixion the go-to,
erasable pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like you ma'am, so
they're giving you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheers and applauds)
- Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, keep
up all the inspiration
it's so creative.
Thank you so much and thank you to all
our guests this hour,
Josh Duhamel, Sosie Bacon,
Antonia Lafaso, Nate Arena, Chad and JT
All the great day, if it's
not well try and change it.